Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
>> Hello Martin. [laughter]
>> [gasps]
>> Hello, Walter.
>> Hi.
>> Are you doing okay?
>> I am feeling very chirpy.
>> That's good. Are [clears throat] you
ready to face the iceberg?
>> No, it looks like the ship has
penetrated the iceberg. I wish it were
that far, but uh looks like it it could
just make it that ship, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well,
uh prophecy says it will.
>> Well, let's see.
>> Let's see. Let's open with a word of
prayer. Our heavenly father, thank you
for once again bringing us together.
Thank you for the opportunity to do
these discussions and we ask that you
now enlighten our minds and help us
through this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Martin, I think we've reached the point
where
the news is just augmenting the story
every single day. Huh. I
>> It's now not a question of if anymore.
That's just a question of when
>> when a long time ago I said we don't
want to be a news agency but we we use
the news now just to show how everything
is happening uh and fulfilling the
prophecies.
>> Yes,
>> we are really
>> very interesting
>> rushing towards this iceberg.
>> Yes. Well, let's see how shall we stand.
I don't even know whether we'll get to
the how will we stand portion
>> with all the things that are happening
but let's just have a look. Will you
stand? So Martin, we were talking about
this new situation
where you have uh church states all over
the world and last time we spoke about
how they are beginning to implement
this, how the uh Abrahamic accord is
making room for coexistence with the
state of Israel.
>> Mhm.
and the Islamic countries all around and
they are bringing in their their
religious and political unions
and they will want to be under Sharia
law. And then you have the situation in
Europe and in the United States.
>> Mhm.
>> Where uh well very interesting little
video came out. We're not going to show
it because it's in German.
>> Mhm. of the Muslims saying they're going
to take over Germany and the Christians
saying no way this is not going to
happen. This is a Christian country and
all this uh activity to maybe deport
people.
>> They don't want to fall in with the
religious paradigm of the nation in
which they are living. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So this is very interesting. So they
want to deport the people that have
let's say an Islamic view or are very
strict about it. If they're willing to
fall into place and to accept the
situation as it is in a Christian
nation historically fine culture then
they can stay.
>> You can be an atheist. You can be
whatever you like as long as you are a
cultural Christian.
>> Yeah. you adhere to the to the laws of
the country.
>> Correct. And therefore those that don't
comply, they will have to be deported.
And these voices are getting louder and
louder and louder. And so you'll have
Muslim countries, you'll have under
Sharia law, you'll have uh [snorts]
Jewish nation under
biblical law uh without Christ, of
course.
>> Yeah. And then you'll have the Christian
nations which are under paper law
[laughter]
>> and accept Christ. So none of them have
got it right.
>> No,
>> you have to have the whole package.
Right.
>> And that's why like the Bible says and
we showed last time, they will only be a
small group.
>> It's continuously a little thorn in the
side of every
>> because they want the biblical rule and
they want Christ.
>> Yeah. Because here are they that keep
the commandments of God and not of the
papacy
>> and have the testimony of Jesus
and the faith of Jesus. So you have to
have Christ plus the biblical law. They
don't want that. Isn't it weird? No.
>> They want Christ, but they want papal
law.
>> And they want no Christ and they want
Sharia law.
and they want no Christ and they want to
have biblical law.
>> Well, that's those are the three options
that you have. And then you have those
that want biblical law and Christ.
They're a problem
>> no matter where you go.
>> It's weird.
>> Actually, it is.
>> It is because that's
>> the thing is prophecy predicted that
this is going to be the case, right?
>> Mhm.
>> They're not going to accept biblical
law. They're going to accept the mark of
the beast and the authority of the
beast, paper law.
>> They're going to do that.
And the Jews are not going to accept
Christ as that man said. They prefer to
go to
>> Awitz.
And the Muslims are not going to accept
either. They're going to have Sharia
law.
>> Yeah.
>> Interesting.
>> And it's also interesting this like the
Bible says, they all have a choice.
>> It's not being forced on them. They do
the enforcing, but God's not enforcing
anything.
>> Correct. And and if you have an
atheistic state, that's fine, too,
because then you have neither. You have
neither biblical law nor Christ.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's okay. But if you want both,
you're in trouble.
>> And then that also tells you that when
you are busy and part of a mainstream
thing, the road is narrow.
>> Yes.
>> So maybe think twice on that stream that
you're on.
>> Ah, absolutely. So let's see what's
happening in the United States. For
example,
Chip Roy and other Republicans are
pushing this bill to block and deport
Sharia law adherent aliens.
And they claim that they are an
existential threat to what?
>> To the philosophy of the Christian
state. Right.
>> Yeah. So America is facing an
existential threat. The spread of Sharia
law. Now it's not only America. The same
noise is coming from Germany. The same
noise is coming from France. The same
noise is coming from Britain. The same
noise is coming from Belgium. The same
noise is coming from the Netherlands.
The same noise is coming from Poland.
The same carries on and on and on.
Coming from Italy, you name it. Right.
>> Mhm. So this is obviously the trend that
we're moving to
>> having religious church states [snorts]
adhering to whatever religion is
prevalent in that region.
Okay. So from Texas to every state in
the union instances of Sharia law
adherence have threatened the American
way of life. seeking to replace our
legal system and constitution with an
incompatible ideology that diminishes
the rights of women, children,
individuals of different faith. So
according to the press release, Europe
should be a wakeup call to America
showing what the spread of Sharia law
looks like. the erosion of the West.
Any alien in the United States found to
be an adherent of Sharia law by the
Secretary of State, Secretary of
Homeland Security or attorney general
shall have an immigration benefit,
immigration relief or visa revoked by
considered inadmissible or deportable
and shall be removed from the United
States. So, this is something that
they're pushing for.
>> Yeah. So you either fall in with the
ideology or you're out. We will not
tolerate two kinds of clashing
ideologies.
>> No. And it sounds exactly like if you
put it in a religious context what
Douglas Wilson said.
>> Yes. But the interesting thing is we'll
tolerate it. They say
>> if it's regionally different.
But none of the regions will tolerate
those that keep the commandments of God
and
hold to the testimony of Jesus. They're
not acceptable anywhere.
>> No,
>> they're going to be a thorn in the
flesh.
>> So, Israel praises Trump as the modern
Cyrus the Great. And the question is,
was this prophetic? Now, of course, this
is setting up the Jewish state.
>> Yeah.
which is Christless, right?
>> That's it
>> by definition.
>> And the whole evangelical world is
longing for this and praying for this
and blessing Israel that this might
happen.
>> Does that make any sense?
>> No, it does not.
>> Because they have got a skewed idea of
what prophecy says. They think that it
has to happen so that the antichrist can
go and sit in the temple.
>> All right? So the the Christians think
the Messiah has come. The Jews think
their Messiah has not come. He's
definitely not going to be Christ. So
who's he going to be? Martin.
>> And the interesting thing is those that
believe that he is Christ.
>> Yeah.
>> Even amongst the Jews are looking for a
national deliverer.
>> Yes.
>> Uh but uh the Bible tells he's going to
be a deliverer from sin and lead to
righteousness. Right.
>> Yeah. They want to set up the kingdom.
>> Yeah.
>> Everybody wants a physical kingdom.
>> Before Christ will come and re recreate.
>> Okay.
>> Because he's going to recreate and then
the kingdom will be.
>> So those that long for the kingdom that
Christ will be setting up will be in
juiposition to those who want to set it
up now on his behalf.
>> Yeah.
>> Because obviously he seems to be
incapable of doing it. So, we'll do it
for him.
>> Yeah. Or even they say that they'll do
it and then he can come and rain. That's
>> all right. So, let's see what what this
video is about.
>> Was just walking back to my hotel and I
came across this. Wow.
They're calling
Trump
Cyrus the Great.
Cyrus the Great is alive.
Wow. That's incredible. You stand before
the people of Israel not as another
American president, but as a giant of
Jewish history. One for whom we must
look back two and a half millennia into
the midst of time to find a parallel.
Cyrus the Great. You, President Donald
J. Trump, are a colossus who will be
enshrined in the pantheon of history.
Thousands of years from now, Mr.
President, the Jewish people will
remember you. We are a nation that
remembers.
Far from being a local struggle, what we
are witnessing is a global struggle, a
global battle between the forces of
extremism, radicalism, and
fundamentalism,
and those of freedom, liberty, and
democracy.
What the world needs now is not
appeasers who feed the crocodile in the
hope that they will be eaten last like
the kind we have seen recently at the UN
General Assembly. And by the way,
President Trump, your team has checked
the teleprompterss. It is working
beautifully.
What the world needs
What the world needs now are more
leaders who are brave, resolute, strong,
and bold. The world needs more Trumps.
[applause]
>> The current non-Jewish Messiah was
chosen to be of service to the Jewish
people and the Jewish Messiah.
President Trump's right ear was grazed
in a symbolic gesture of Exodus 21:6
where the Torah states that a servant
who wants to remain with his master
needs to have his right ear pierced.
Trump was designated as God's servant
and anointed one just like Cyrus the
Great almost 2400 years ago.
We have clarified in several videos that
the absolute deadline for the redemption
is by the end of the Jewish year 5,787
which corresponds to October 2nd, 2027.
1,167
days from today. And I have good reason
to believe Donald Trump was chosen to be
the one to redeem the sins of Asov
through offering his assistance in
rebuilding the holy temple on the Temple
Mount and establishing the Jewish
kingdom over all of mankind in
Jerusalem.
>> Martin, that man should be in trouble
for mentioning 2027.
[laughter]
>> What's he doing there?
>> I don't know. [clears throat] What is
the man doing? 2027.
That date is also very interesting
because the the Jewish calendar seems to
be a few hundred years short, right?
>> Uhhuh. Yeah.
>> Because according to the biblical
chronology, uh 2027
should be around about 6,000 years.
>> And they are a little bit short.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So what happened there?
>> Please explain.
>> Yeah. Well, if you study the history,
you will see that they do not calculate
the Meo Persian time of history.
>> They only deal with the exile period.
>> Uhhuh.
>> So they are short of those time blocks
which they have not incorporated.
So if you incorporate those, well then
the date is what the Bible says and not
what the Jewish calendar says. just for
clarification.
>> Very very good.
>> It's very interesting.
>> So Martin, we have Osiris.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh he will see that the Jews have
their state. Now the interesting thing
is Cyrus the Great. He permitted the
rebuilding of the temple.
>> Mhm.
>> And Das after him.
>> Yeah. After the false smearis who tried
to interfere with Cyrus's decree to
rebuild the temple was removed by Das,
then Das gave them a self- sustaining
>> political system, right? But they were
still subject to the nation's u overall
rule. So when they decreed that they
could be self-governing again, they were
still self-governing under the overall
umbrella of this world political power.
And this is the way it's going to be.
There's going to be a world political
power
that has to keep the peace. Whether you
call it the United Nations or whatever
you want to call it, they're going to
have to keep the peace. So there's an
accord. Yeah.
>> And that's the Abrahamic Accord. that
that's that one that they are free as
long as it fits into the
>> as it has to fit into the the system. So
you can keep your religion and your
political structure as you will and we
will keep ours because in ancient times
the ancients believed that deities were
regional.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Okay. So you didn't uh dethrone the
deity.
you might dethrone the people, but they
were too scared to dethrone the deity.
[clears throat]
>> So when Nebuchadnezzar, for example,
conquered Jerusalem and uh took the
Judeans into exile,
he sent people into Samaria,
>> but he told them to study the rules of
the deity of the region.
And that is where sort of syncratistic
religion developed like the Samaritans
have which were based on Yave but
actually were mixed with Baal worship
synratism. [clears throat]
>> So it'll be the same here. The regional
deity will be the Jewish deity
and in the other regions the regional
deity will be whatever is there. In this
case of the Middle East now it would be
Allah.
>> Yeah. So they live in harmony with their
own deity.
>> Yes. As long as you don't rock the boat.
>> Yeah.
>> And you live in harmony and peace and
you do your thing
>> and don't proitize.
>> Yes. Well, that's actually very
prominent these days.
>> Oh yes. Don't do that. You're not
allowed to convert anyone because the
deity of the region will be very upset.
>> Yeah. And I mean Russia's got that law
as well.
>> Russia just introduced that law together
with the papacy.
>> Yeah. And the papacy is very strong on
it because the papacy is the mother of
all the harlots [laughter]
>> of course and uh Francis Pope Francis he
vehemently said
>> no proalitizing
>> and as the gentleman said you know we
don't want fundamentalism.
>> Now it's very strange what is orthodox
Jewism other than fundamentalism
without Christ? Isn't fundamentalism the
definition that you believe exactly what
it says and stands there?
>> Correct. Now they they claim it's the
Torah, but actually it's the Talmud,
right?
>> That's why they stick to that and they
don't want to move.
>> Yes. because you I I was in the in
Jerusalem
>> and I've told the story many times when
this uh rabbi who had hit some hard
times wanted a little donation
[snorts] and I made his life
uncomfortable by saying I would give him
a donation if he would have a little
chat with me which is very very uh uh
>> disturbing to them. But uh the need was
greater than the disturbing.
So he sat with me and I wanted to talk
about Daniel and about Isaiah chapter
53.
And he got so hot under the collar
and I wanted to know why he got so hot
under the collar. And he said because I
have no right to interpret scripture.
>> Mhm. Oh, that sounds famil.
>> Only the rabbi has the right to
interpret scripture. And remember that
Catholic guy we showed last time,
[laughter] he said, "Only the church,
the pope has the right to interpret
scripture and you have to shut up.
>> You're not allowed to read." Typical.
>> So you have the ability to read, but
you're not allowed to use it.
>> So what's the point of giving the people
the Bible? So let's not give it to them.
Let's just give them the catechism. Then
you know what the pope says about it,
which is always a lot of nonsense. But
you must be careful because if you're
not a theologian, then you won't
understand a direct contradiction in two
Bibles.
>> That is a very good point, Martin. You
have to be a theologian to understand
two contradictions
>> and to reconcile them.
>> So it's everywhere this same mindset.
>> Okay. So let me ask you a question while
while you're talking about that. The
Abrahamic Accord
>> isn't it in itself a contradiction for
sure because you have an accord between
those that accept Christ and those that
don't. And didn't the Bible say that you
can only be part of the spiritual Israel
and seed of Abraham if you accept
Christ? Martin the world is too
confusing [laughter] for me.
So Martin, we have Osiris the Great in
the world at the moment according to
these sources. We have a great
peacemaker
>> in the world and that is all reminiscent
of Matthew 24, isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> So you have all of these things and then
you still have the Hegelian dialectic
going.
>> Mhm.
>> Because you have to change mindsets,
right? That that needs an egelian
dialectic. And then there are those that
say he should get the Nobel Peace Prize.
>> Yeah.
>> And then they give it to someone else
and let's see what happens then. Yeah.
>> It's a great honor to be involved with
so many. So uh the person who actually
got the Nobel Prize uh called today
called me and said that I'm accepting
this in honor of you because you really
deserved it. That a very nice thing to
do. I I didn't I didn't say then give it
to me though. because I think she might
have. She was very nice and I've been,
you know, I've been helping her along
the way. She they've they need a lot of
help in Venezuela.
>> Indeed, they do need help and indeed he
has been helping and we are honored to
have Maria Corina Machado join us, the
new recipient of the Nobel Peace Prize.
Maria, welcome. Congratulations. And
tell our viewers why you decided to
dedicate this award to President Donald
Trump.
Thank you very much, Rachel, and to all
of you for what you have done for
Venezuela. And I decided to dedicated to
President Trump because he deserves it.
Because not only has he been involved in
only a few months in solving eight wars,
but his actions have been decisive to
have Venezuela now at a threshold of
freedom after 26 years of tyranny.
So Martin, this agenda, this peace peace
agenda,
this uh categorizing of religious state
entities,
moving people that don't agree in a
particular region with the deity of
choice there, deport them to a region
where their deity is in control.
This is happening. It sounds like a
repeat of what happened in the ancient
near east.
>> Yeah, it's it is actually a repeat of
what happened in Cyrus's day and all of
these.
>> Okay.
>> And the interesting thing is while Trump
was standing for president,
>> he denied being part of project 2025.
>> Yeah. He even denied having any
knowledge of it. And then eventually he
implemented virtually every parameter
except the last one which is the
protection under the family
>> and the introduction of Sunday Sabbath.
>> And now all of a sudden he no longer
denies it.
>> So it's not necessary to deny it
anymore. Is that so?
>> So let's read what Time magazine said
about it.
>> Trump is no longer denying support for
project 2025.
That's quite a turnaround, isn't it?
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> President Donald Trump has changed his
tune on the Conservative policy plan and
project 2025 after actively distancing
himself from it for months during his
reelection campaign.
So he announced on Thursday that he
would be meeting with Office of
Management and Budget Director Russell
Forb. He of project 2025 fame to decide
which Democrat agencies most of which
are political scam he recommends to be
cut and whether or not those cuts will
be temporary or permanent. I find this
interesting
that he wants to dismantle
the
woke agenda and the left agenda
>> and that the left should be playing into
his hand by giving him the opportunity
through the shutdown.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And not relinquishing for one moment.
And they have ridiculous requests that
even their own party says what's going
on here? What's going on? And Martin,
I am reminded of Quigley.
>> Mhm.
>> You know who Quigley was? He was the
professor at Georgetown University, a
Jesuit, of course.
>> Carol Quigley.
>> Yes. And he's the one that was the
mentor of um presidents like Bill
Clinton for example.
And he said that the world is being
controlled by a small group
>> of which he is a member.
>> Oh. [snorts]
[laughter]
>> And we showed who that small group is.
>> Of course, it's a Jesuit professor. So
he was obviously quite plainly saying
the Jesuits are in control out of the
horse's mouth. Right.
>> Now the interesting thing is he also
said that the two party system is
basically a scam.
>> Yeah. It's a Hegelian dialectic.
>> And he said, you know, that is so that
you can get rid of the rascals and
change policies and but basically behind
the scenes when they get to their
Masonic little
>> little chambers and their Jesuit little
retreats and enclaves, the policy is
decided whether it's from the left or
whether it's from the right. It's it's
all nonsense. [snorts]
>> So that's what he said.
>> Well, you know what? Well, I embellished
it a little bit, but he said the
two-party system is actually
cooperative.
>> And and you can see it when Trump, for
example,
uh introduced levies and and trade,
finances, the left was screaming like
crazy.
>> And when Biden came in, he never changed
the policy at all. He just carried on.
So obviously if he was screaming like
crazy, why didn't he change it,
>> right?
>> It wasn't for the for the greater
purpose.
>> It wasn't for the greater common good.
>> So this is very interesting. So here
they are creating a shutdown which gives
Donald Trump the opportunity to get rid
of all the agencies that are a problem
for him.
>> Yeah.
>> So which one will not receive funding?
all those that belong to the left, but
the left is enabling it. Does that make
sense?
>> No.
>> I mean,
>> unless it's part of a plan.
>> There's a plan.
>> Okay.
>> I mean, you've got the they got funding
for the military, but he wants the
military.
>> All right. Now Martin, if the left is
controlled by the small group of which
Quigley was a part, the Jesuits,
and the right is controlled by the same
group, then isn't this an interesting
game?
>> Yeah. That's why we always say like
spirit of prophecy also says, don't get
sucked into it. Don't get sucked in
>> and be an observer. So despite Trump's
repeated insistence that he didn't know
anything about project 2025, however, he
had close ties with a number of its
authors, several of whom have served in
his administration, including for
and he's giving them high positions
where decision making is part and parcel
of the issue. Right?
And since he returned to the White House
in January, his second administration
has taken steps to implement a number of
the proposals detailed in the over
900page document. Now, amid the
government shutdown,
Trump is moving to further fulfill
project 2025 goals of reducing the
federal workforce and extending his
executive powers. and it appears openly
embracing the plan. So here he's given
this marvelous opportunity
by the opposition that basically should
want to prevent him from doing all these
things but doesn't
>> Yeah.
>> actually enhances it under a different
pretext. Interesting game. Yeah.
>> Yeah. It it I
I've always
I'd never liked politics, but now it's
so interesting to watch if you can bring
it in with what the Bible says. You just
previously said that Quickly said that
it is run by the small group, both
sides. But the Bible also said they all
sit at the same table.
>> They sit at the same table. They are
having a wonderful conversation. The
king of the north and the king of the
south.
And then Martin, a little bit of
interesting history. The Confederate
statue reinstalled in DC after Trump's
executive order. Now, what statue was
this? Of course, this is a statue that
was removed after uproars with the Black
Lives Matter movement because the person
involved, Albert Pike, of course,
Scottish right 33deree Freemason,
uh, who wrote Morals and Dogma,
basically the Bible of of Freemasonry,
was involved in the creation of the Klux
Clan.
So obviously there's a lot of racial
tension in all of this and they removed
that statue and it's fascinating that
Donald Trump ordered that it be
reinstated. Right.
>> So the National Park Service announced
in August that it would reinstall the
statue to align with two executive
orders signed by President Trump.
Significant work was done to restore it.
The park service said the statue honors
Pike's leadership in Freemasonry.
>> Interesting. Not as a general of
[laughter]
Freemasonry.
It made no mention of his time in the
Confederate Army and his work to stop
black men and women from gaining the
right to vote. Pike himself served
dishonorably. He took up arms against
the United States, misappropriated
funds, and was ultimately captured and
imprisoned by his own troops. Not before
he became the hero of Freemasonry.
And when I was in that 33°ree temple,
that mason shouted at me and said to me,
"You are standing on holy ground." And I
said, "What's so holy about it? It's
Pike's grave." [laughter]
Okay. So his bones were holy and nowhere
do I read that in scripture.
>> So I didn't have a problem walking over
that hallowed terrain.
>> But the beast system also has the same
philosophy.
>> Oh yes.
>> It's amazing.
>> You go down into into some of those
areas in the Vatican.
>> Mhm.
>> And there you have the tombs of John
Paul II and you have to basically kneel
down and pray.
So I was also in the Vatican
and there was a lady in front of me and
when she got to the casket of John Paul
II,
she knelt down
and she prayed. I don't know how long
she prayed, but for quite a while. And
the Swiss guard was standing behind me
and he did nothing. He tolerated it
completely. But I didn't kneel down
>> because uh I don't think it's
appropriate to kneel down at the bones
of the antichrist. So I kept on standing
and I had to wait because you can't pass
until the lady got up and moved on. And
then I stopped to take a picture and the
Swiss guard shoved me. I had to get on
with it. But the lady was allowed to
pray, but I wasn't going to pray. So I
was nongrat
obviously has high regard for this
particular individual.
>> It's the same thing running all through
this.
>> It's steeped in it. And who is behind
Freemasonry? The Jesuits.
>> The Jesuits.
>> Who's behind the Illuminati?
The Jesuits. Adam Vice,
founder of the Illuminati.
Jesuit. There is no such thing as an ex
Jesuit. No,
maybe just an undercover one.
>> Yes, unless he really converts, which
has happened,
>> and then he's subject to the bullet.
>> Well, like that Jesuit priest that
converted, Roberta.
>> Yes,
>> correct. And he had many things to say
that were fascinating. I also once had a
lecture that I was giving. I think it
was, if I remember correctly, it was in
Canada. could have been in the US, but I
think it was in Canada. And after the
lecture, uh, a man came up to me and he
said that he was a Jesuit
and that I had rattled his cage.
And I that is strange to me because
obviously he was there as an observer,
but he wasn't a an initiate Jesuit. He
was a young Jesuit. So once you get
initiated and go through the oaths,
there are also levels of Jesuitism and
le levels of informed and non-informed.
>> It's a lot like Freemasonry.
>> It's built on the same system.
>> And then he he said that he would have
to go and rethink his position. So
Jesuits can be reached for sure.
>> I don't know what happened to him after
that, but it's interesting. And not uh
even the Adventist church in some places
seems to be waking up to the situation.
Although up until now they have been in
a deep coma [laughter] and a deep sleep
with the sound waves of snoring echoing
over the city walls.
But some of them seem to be waking up to
the situation. And the Michigan
Conference issued a very interesting uh
document, Rest, Worship, and Government.
A faithdriven vision for work and rest
raises church state questions in the
future of US labor policy.
>> It has to come via the labor policy.
>> Yes.
>> Because the trade unions have to be
involved, right?
Jonathan Barry, nominated as solicitor
of labor for the US Department of Labor,
authored the labor law section of the
project 2025 policy agenda. This is
fascinating stuff.
>> It's just amazing. I mean, if you built
a puzzle and you get the pieces to start
fitting and you're so satisfied. And
this is the same.
>> This one fits beautifully. This one fits
beautifully. Among several proposals, he
recommends amending the Fair Labor
Standard Act to require overtime pay for
work performed on the Sabbath defined as
Sunday or another day of religious
observance.
as a way of honor longstanding religious
and culturous traditions around weekly
rest.
If confirmed, Barry would serve as the
DO's chief legal officer with
independent authority to enforce over
180 federal labor laws. So Martin,
people are being put in place that will
follow the agenda
>> and they are project 2025 individuals.
So even if Trump does not say yes, I am
implementing project 2025, he's doing it
by his action.
>> Correct. And putting the people in place
who can do it on his behalf.
>> Fascinating.
Now you remember Martin that we said
when this new pope
Leo
>> Yes.
>> became the American pope that his agenda
was going to be rar Novarum.
>> Yeah. because that's why he took the
name
>> which is labor law
>> and his predecessor who wrote re rerum
novarum said that the state must enforce
Sunday [snorts] legislation so let's
just listen whether something is
happening behind the scenes we already
have the individual now in government
who is supposed to implement 2025
uh labor legislation let's see what else
is being did.
>> Boy, you talk about $140,000
and change. You talk about that versus
$37,000. I'm just thinking back to your
reference to RAM Novarum, the dignity of
the individual. I mean, how are you
supposed to raise a family on $37,000?
The difference between that and what
you've been able to secure at UPS is
incredible. Let me just ask you this.
Amazon is also one of the biggest
offenders when it comes to not
negotiating with workers who've decided
to unionize. You mentioned Staten
Island. I think they're still waiting
for a first. So the NLRB so they are you
know um contradicting themselves every
turn of the way just to use union
avoidance and I believe there was a uh
article in the economic policy institute
uh which was dead on that stated Amazon
has zero intention of engaging in real
good faith collective bargaining with
representatives of Staten Island
workers. In fact their business model
which relies on high worker turnover and
avoiding responsibility for their
employees is designed to make union
organizing nearly impossible. In that
context, tell us why the Faster Labor
Contracts Act is is so important.
Important to put a shot clock on these
big corporations so they can't just say,
"Well, you voted to unionize." You know,
good luck to you. We're never ever going
to sit down and talk to you.
>> Yeah. The Faster Labor Contracts Act uh
has timelines.
It has uh consequences for bad behavior.
And I think it's important that uh if
and when this faster labor contracts act
is passed, bad actors like Amazon will
be forced to the table, will be forced
to negotiate, and will have to agree to
a first-time contract.
>> Okay. Now, Martin, he used the word
forced.
>> That's amazing.
>> Now, Amazon's a pretty big company,
right?
>> It's one of the biggest um I think if
not the biggest.
>> All right. Now, uh, weren't all of these
people visitors at the Vatican when they
signed that, uh, economic accord?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> With all the oligarchs signing that
they, you know, are on board with this
kind of thing. So my personal view, I
could be wrong of course, is that this
is another little Hegelian dialectic
where somebody plays hard ball so that
the people become upset who work in that
situation so that big brother can come
in and set the record straight on behalf
of the people and on behalf of the
common good
>> and with legislation
>> and with legislation to force everyone
into the mold.
And the labor unions will be one of the
means to bring about a time of trouble
such as never was or is this on the
table
>> definitely with Barry being there this
act that wants to becoming law you can
see they will be forcing you they he
said it
>> they're going to force you and now all
we need is a revival of the religious
aspect [clears throat]
>> and then we have the whole package deal
right we have the labor laws we have the
government and we have the church all
involved in this one-way traffic and
we're going to be a Christian nation in
the United States and the Europeans are
going to look over there and say, "You
know what? We're so sick and tired of
our situation
that we want to follow suit. Mhm.
>> We want to get rid of everything that
doesn't agree with cultural Christianity
and we will become a Christian nation as
well and we will have our laws and we
will be happy whether we are atheists or
not. We'll go along with it.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you have to have the church
filling up again.
And you don't want old coders.
[laughter]
You want people that can climb
barricades.
>> Well, revivals and uh reformations has
always been done by the young.
>> All right. So, Zedman
returning to church in surprising
numbers in faith resurgence.
At a time when America is wrestling with
declining church attendance, a
surprising reversal has pastors and
researchers talking about the
possibility of a new revival.
Gen Z has been known as the least
religious generation, but new numbers
show young men are bucking the trend.
They're going back to church. H the
answer for the church is not to adopt
its message to the times but to preach
and teach and defend the truth of the
Bible in a strong but loving way. Now
the interesting thing is they're not
defending the Bible, they're defending
tradition.
>> Yeah. Unfortunately, you do have voices
like this and I totally agree with what
he's saying here, but you have to take
it the whole the whole
>> take the whole thing. Bible sales jumped
22% in 2024
compared to less than 1% growth for the
print books overall according to the
Circana book scan. So modern they're
reading the Bible but they're following
tradition
>> unfortunately because when they read the
Bible they don't
and I I feel for it because I used to be
like this when pre few years ago you
read the Bible and then you just have a
a little bit of a
um con conception of how what it says
and then you go and listen to the pastor
and then he becomes the norm and not
what this the the Bible is saying.
Kirk inspires generation Z to trade
parties for prayer as college frat
sparks faith revival experts say. Now I
just read today that Erica Kirk
says that she has this feeling that her
husband is in communication
and is setting the trend for what is
happening and planning up there in
heaven.
And uh that's very fascinating because
that's basically spiritualism.
>> That is
>> and Little Light Studio did a very
interesting one on that not so long ago
>> and perhaps people could look at that
one. Maybe even put a link in
>> I will
>> because they're doing a great job so we
don't have to repeat what they are
saying why that is spiritualism.
Fraternity houses throughout the country
are trading beers for Bibles as [snorts]
university students are turning to
Christianity in the wake of conservative
activist Charlie Kirk's assassination.
The movement has spread across the
nation, most recently taking root in
Kapa Sigma Fraternity House. Now those
are all secret society
organizations,
>> breeding grounds.
>> Breeding grounds. Yes. where of course
you have little secret rituals and
secret handshakes. It's basically
masonic.
>> Yeah, it's the stepping stone.
>> Yes, they have many suborganizations
which are their drawing portals where
they suck them in, put them into
leadership positions and send them out.
>> So this is happening in East Carolina
University, North Carolina. Dozens of
college students gathered for an evening
prayer. So they they call it a night of
hope. I think it's easy for young person
to think their whole life is ahead of
them, Elk said. But when someone they
look up to that's not too much older
than them gets taken out in a public
way, I think it's easy for them to have
more questions and to to become
involved. Right. Well, that's we we said
when we first we've done a whole episode
on it, it will be a cat that um
assassination
will definitely be a catalyst.
>> Yes. [snorts]
>> And this is happening now.
>> Now, if you take our situation in this
country,
our government here is basically also an
alliance with trade unions.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Very much so.
>> A very official one. How long does it
take to organize barricades and
revolutions?
>> A day.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. One phone call
and it's done.
>> Yeah.
>> So these things can happen very quickly.
>> Very quickly.
>> And now let's let's look at the left
[laughter]
because this is always very interesting.
Let's look at the left. And well, the
most charismatic potential leader for
the left is obviously Nuome right
>> now. He invokes scripture in an attack
on the GOP
over the shutdown affecting food
assistance. He calls it cruelty is the
policy. So, of course, you have the
right doing what they're doing and then
you have the left screaming about what
they are doing.
And uh let's see what happens here
because I find this very very
interesting. Gavin Newsome invoked
biblical teachings while criticizing
Republican leadership and the Trump
administration for federal government
shutdowns impact on food assistance. So,
he's drawing it to the daily needs
level.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, it's the same that the
Catholic Church is focusing on as well.
Now, let's just see where he comes from.
And this is in this article, and it's
from October 26, 2025. So, this is very
recent, right?
Nuome, who was raised Catholic and
graduated from Santa Clara University, a
Jesuit institution,
has occasionally cited his faith
background and Jesuit education when
discussing social issues.
I remember when we when we did the same
with um Anthony Fouchy.
>> Yes,
>> he was the same. He was boasting and
very um vocal about his Jesuit
upbringing.
>> All right, Martin. So these people are
all Jesuit trained whether they come
from the left, whether they come from
the right, is there no agreement? Can
two walk together lest they agree or is
this a Hegelian dialectic? Obviously it
is. If you if somebody is watching this
episode for the first time and haven't
seen anything else, go and watch our
previous one where we clearly explain
what the Jesuit is.
>> Okay. So, in his remarks Tuesday, he
referenced a wonderful Jesuit university
and said, "Lessons from the New
Testament emphasize feeding the hungry
and caring for the poor." He sounds just
like the pope now.
>> Yeah.
>> And once again, we must just clarify. We
don't say that is wrong, but that's the
focus. That's to take everything out.
And
>> that's focusing on the food and focusing
on the this, which is right.
>> Mhm.
>> But cutting Christ's mediation out of
the picture,
replacing his sacrifice with a morsel of
bread.
>> Yeah. and an intermediary that has never
been mentioned in the Bible, namely the
papal system, the pope and his pates and
all the deceased saints, anyone you wish
to have in that plethora, whether they
walked from Protestantism to
Catholicism, it doesn't matter. like
Cardinal Newman
>> Newman
>> who has now been declared of course by
the previous popes as a saint.
>> Yes.
>> So he's an intermediary
>> and he will be and will show something.
>> Would you like to pray at the bones of
that moldy specimen?
>> No, I don't want to be close to bones at
all.
>> No, let's stay away from those bones.
Let the bonesmen go and do that.
[laughter]
Now Vance visits the church where
Christians believe Jesus Jesus was
crucified resurrected amid Israel Hamas
ceasefire. This is of course the
Catholic venue.
If you go into Jerusalem
uh they have the church where this
supposedly took place or built over the
place. And then you have a totally
different Golata outside of the city
which is far more in line and biblical
which is of course totally neglected. So
the whole world is just running on
nothing but lies.
>> Yeah that's true. when we were there
last year
with um Frana Di the same we went
actually we didn't even know we were in
this church because we went to the other
places as well and like you said it's
such a
>> it's chalk and cheese right
>> it's it's actually a nightmare because
there's so many there's different places
that says it's the same it's for the
same reason there
>> yeah and the interesting thing is they
say you know he was crucified outside of
the city
>> but this place is obviously inside the
city. So they said, but the walls were
different in those days. And then while
I was there a few years ago, they were
digging up the walls and the walls were
exactly where they should be. So this
was definitely inside the city.
>> And uh they had actually had a sewage
problem. So they had to dig down to
solve the sewage problem and they
discovered the old Damascus gate.
>> Oh. [snorts] So the wall was obviously
>> much lower but
>> where it was and this place is a fake
place totally fake.
>> But then uh you know you have very many
fake things in Catholicism.
>> What about the Lanta Scala Martin that
stairs
>> that stairway that supposedly was the
one that led to where Pilate was saying
behold the man Echohomo. Mhm.
>> And then one day this stairway appeared
suddenly miraculously in Rome
>> having been transported by angels.
>> And then they built this uh edifice over
it, this church over it.
>> And it still had the blood stains from
Jesus on the stairs. So if you go up
there, you have little glass plates over
it and the people crawl up there and
kiss the glass plates and that's where
the reformation started.
>> Yes.
>> The just shall live by faith. Now how
can anybody in his right mind believe
such nonsense?
>> Unfortunately, that's how you are duped.
But just explain why you say the
reformation started there. Because
Martin Luther visited Rome
and he expected something, you know,
religious, but what he found was pomp
and ceremony and debortery.
>> And he being a a devout Catholic, but
having read Romans already, he was in a
in a terrible conflict. But he went
through the rituals and he crawled up
those stairs on his knees for which you
get an indulgence.
>> In other words, you get time off from
paying for your own sins even though
Christ has paid for them. And he
obviously was thinking about this as he
went up. And then he had this revelation
that the just will not be rewarded by
crawling on their knees and kissing fake
stairs and fake [clears throat] plaques
and fake blood droplets which never ever
existed there, especially not after
2,000 years.
And then it struck him and the words
echoed in his mind. The just shall live
by faith. Faith in what? In the
completed works of Jesus Christ. I don't
have to chastise myself.
>> He has been chastised for me. Isaiah is
absolutely clear in chapter 53
>> that he paid the price for me. By his
stripes I am healed. I don't have to
inflict stripes on myself
>> in order to do this.
>> And then
>> and he and he got up halfway. He never
completed it. Martin, he lost an
indulgence. [laughter]
That's a nightmare.
>> But he gained everlasting life.
>> Maybe we're alive today or if he were
alive under the previous pope, he could
have just followed his tweets and gotten
an indulgence without crawling up the
lanta scala. You know this is the kind
of nonsense yeah
>> that is broadcast in the world.
So what did he have to say? What did
Vance have to say? He said I'm immensely
grateful to the Greek, Armenian and
Catholic priests who care for this most
sacred of places. It's a fake place.
>> Vance wrote on X on Thursday sharing
photos of his visit to the church. May
the Prince of Peace have mercy upon us
and bless our efforts for peace. I am
also grateful to the Franciscan monks
who celebrated a private mass for my
family and many of the Americans working
for peace. Martin,
this is joining church and state
rhetoric. That's why that we show this
because this is not even closing the gap
between chosen state. This is gluing it
together.
>> Yes. And what is it? This is Catholicism
and
evangelicalism.
>> Yeah. Because
>> because they call themselves evangelical
Catholics joining together in what? In
traditions based on falsehoods.
Unfortunately,
>> so obviously this rift between
Catholicism
and um
>> Protestantism
is dissolved, right?
>> Well, 2014 you showed that whole signing
[snorts] of the ecumenical charter.
You've got uh the 500 here one that you
showed where
>> correct
>> and then you had um Tony Palmer who said
>> yes and you know Martin the 31st of
October
>> Mhm. It's a fascinating date, right?
Because the 31st of October
>> is Reformation Day,
>> but it's also Halloween. So, you can
pick and choose whether you want to be
uh reminded of your Protestant heritage
or whether you want to put a candy bar
on someone's head.
>> Yeah. Now, Donald Trump in a trick and
treat put a candy bar on a kid's head
instead of putting it in his bag. And
there was a big hoo-ha about why would
he put the candy bar on top of the kid's
head instead of in in the bag. So it
seems the White House is quite happy in
celebrating uh Christian norms and
having you know a new office to ensure
Christianity
is treated correctly
and keep Halloween at the same time.
And there is no difference between the
pagan world and the Christian world and
the Protestant world and the Catholic
world. And of course the church of
England which we spoke about last time
which is now so masonic that it's no
longer a church and the king of England
or the queen of England is the head of
the church of England. And there was
this rift when they [snorts] separated
from Rome.
>> Mhm.
>> Which of course has been rescended
secretly
by visits by Ratzinga etc.
[clears throat]
>> where the archbishops worshiped together
at the places of the so-called
reformation
and they honored all the Catholic
martyrs so-called in this issue. So they
were actually showing that they won.
>> Yeah. And now this king of England,
Charles,
goes and publicly prays with the Pope,
demonstrating that the rift is gone.
>> It no longer exists. And in a church
nearby, this chapel in the Vatican where
they prayed together, he got a a special
chair, in other words, basically a
throne.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. which is uh which is
fascinating because it is portraying the
image that the throne of the kings is
again subject to Rome. Oh,
>> it's the symbol symbolism is amazing.
>> It's amazing. They're so in yourrface
these Masons and these Jesuits and the
whole vile compilation. Unfortunately,
the world is so duped that everybody is
love loving this.
>> This is wonderful. Look at the unity we
have. Unity in error.
Let's have a look at it.
>> Beneath Michelangelo's last judgment
where heaven and earth seemed to meet in
paint and light, something extraordinary
unfolded. King Charles III heir to
centuries of division knelt in prayer
beside Pope Leo I 14th under the same
sacred ceiling that once witnessed papal
conclaves and the coronation of saints
for the first time [music] in 500 years
the spiritual leaders of the Anglican
and Catholic traditions prayed together
in unity. This was not just [music] a
royal visit. It was a miracle of grace
meeting history, a living testament that
reconciliation is possible even between
institutions once torn apart by pride,
power, and pain. The cyine chapel filled
with royal choirs and sacred psalms
became more than a masterpiece. It
became a mirror of the human soul. The
fresco of judgment and mercy looked down
as two faiths once divided by doctrine
raised their voices in one prayer. Latin
met English, Rome met Canterbury.
>> It was interesting that you hear what
they said where previously they were
disagreements about doctrine. Now the
doctrines are set aside and ecumenical
get together.
>> Isn't that wonderful? Doctrine is not
important. So let's shove Jesus aside
for the sake of our masonic Jesuit
agreements.
>> Yeah. You remember what Tony Palmer
said? He said, "God will sort out all
our doctrines when we get upstairs."
>> That's wonderful. Yeah.
So, what did the Vatican News have to
say on this issue? Well, King Charles
attends ecumenical prayer service in the
Sistine Chapel. This visit marked the
historic moment in Anglican Catholic
relations, one that has not occurred in
500 years. Two themes marked the
journey, Christian unity and care for
the environment. Isn't that interesting?
There we have the two nonsense issues
again. Unity in error and environmental
issues based on lies.
>> Yeah.
>> Wonderful.
Originally scheduled for April, the
visit was cancelled due to Pope
Francis's ill health, but now of course
it has taken place. And we mustn't
forget Lausi.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Don't forget that Martin
>> because popes are infallible.
>> Yes. Yes. That's why Donald Trump had to
be rebuked with a dice block.
[laughter]
From the opening hymn of the prayer
service, the theme of Christian unity
and ecumenism was evident. The original
text was written by St. Ambrose of
Milan, doctor of the church. It was
translated by St. John Henry Newman,
the vilest creature and [clears throat]
apostate
that Protestantism has produced. The one
who brought in the Oxford movement
[clears throat] changed Protestant
approach and the acceptance of Christ as
the supreme sacrifice. bringing back the
altar, replacing Jesus with a morsel of
bread and transsubstantiation,
making null and void the statement that
by one sacrifice he has forever made
perfect. And this individual was then
rewarded to become a cardinal within the
Catholic Church.
>> And he was so woke that he would have
fitted in just beautifully into some
current societies.
>> Yeah.
That was the real start of the fall of
Protestantism at the Oxford movement.
>> So this Newman was an Anglican for half
of his life before converting to
Catholicism which I don't believe for
one moment he was a Jesuit infiltrator
as far as I'm concerned and he was
playing a role beautifully and is was
rewarded.
>> Yeah. King Charles had attended the
canonization ceremony of the English
theologian in 2019. Now that's what I
was referring to previously
when St. John Henry Newman is said to be
declared a doctor of the church on no
1st November by Pope Leo. So he will now
be a doctor of the church. Martin
>> he's you can see did he do anything good
for the papacy? Oh yes, he was a
champion for the cave.
>> Being rewarded for it.
>> He's being rewarded, but his bones are
moldy and the dead know nothing.
>> He's certainly not interceding as a
saint on behalf of anybody.
So Martin, will he be rewarded for his
apostasy or will he sleep a thousand
years and receive the sentence of the
second death? Fortunately, we leave that
to a higher judge.
>> Yeah. Amen. So, what else did Sky News
report on the issue? Pope gifts Charles
a specially crafted chair
as they pray together in 500 year first.
That's what I said. Martin, is this a
little throne that he gets to be seated
on in Rome?
>> Definitely. Didn't the c they um what do
is the crown not on lease to them from
the pap?
>> Of course it's on lease. It's part of
the Magna Carta.
>> So now they just give him a little
throne that he can come and sit there
next to the main throne.
>> He can have a comfortable spot for his
posterior.
>> But it must be next to the main throne.
>> Yes. No, he's not on the main throne.
The pope is on the main throne.
So today marked the first time a British
monarch has publicly prayed with the
pope in 500 years. The king and queen
joined Pope Leo the 14th for an
ecumenical service in the cyine chapel.
The two-day visit to the holy sea was
understood to be deeply significant for
the king personally who was greatly
looking forward to it having long been
interested in interfaith dialogue. It
also marked a welcome distraction from
the recent negative attention
surrounding the king's brother, Prince
Andrew. And the interesting thing is
when he suits him, he puts on the dress
of an imam and he's equally happy to
pray to Allah
>> who has no son whatsoever
>> and no redemption.
>> And he also does it for he wears monk
clothes. You remember he changed that
he's not the protector of [snorts] the
faith. He's now the protector of faith.
>> Of faith. Yes. But obviously subject to
wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
Now you know this issue of uh climate
change.
It has to be in there for the sake of
the secular world that has to accept
Sunday. Right.
And uh you had this interesting case
with Greta who seems to be on the
climate bandwagon and then again on the
Palestinian bandwagon and then on the
climate bandwagon and any bandwagon that
you can possibly think of.
[laughter]
>> And then you have the anti-graater
activists who try to open their mouths
and say that they are speaking a lot of
nonsense. And you have this young lady
in Germany who fears for her life
because she opposes this nonsense
agenda. And it's interesting that Elon
Musk backs her for an asylum claim.
Isn't this an interesting dialectic?
>> Yeah, for sure. But it just shows you
that the the climate and any anybody
that will be speaking up against the
narrative whether it will be
conservative or liberal like we've shown
you will be
>> correct
>> having problems.
>> And now when they're talking about this
new hurricane that has made landfall
>> oh
>> and been so destructive in Jamaica and
other areas then it's of course climate
change. So you have to
>> you have to keep it going. And Donald
Trump says it's a load of nonsense and
the pope blesses ice blocks and uh you
know it's a it's a ridiculous story.
>> So let's just read what it says here. It
says it is illegal to damage the
reputation of a politician in Germany.
It's interesting right?
>> Yeah that's so you don't have free
speech when it comes to a politician.
>> Okay. This law was extended under Angela
Merkel article 188 and now people are
being arrested and their houses are
being raided for just social media
posts. As soon as I come back to
Germany, I feel that they will try to
arrest me, she explained. Her activism
first attracted attention when she
questioned climate changed orthodoxy and
mass migration policies and was branded
the anti-greta
as a foil to Greta Thunberg. So she
wants to actually support the AFD
[clears throat]
>> which is the right party that wants to
deport people
uh much like you know other nations want
to do. I started becoming known and
internationally recognized as the
anti-greta Tornberg in 2020. Cyp added
Elon has been terrified of going to
Europe and knows that there is an
extremely high threat and has confirmed
this to me personally. That's when I
made the decision to apply for asylum
myself. He gave me his approval for
that. So Martin Elon Musk then is in
harmony with Donald Trump, then he's
fighting with Donald Trump, then he's in
harmony with Donald Trump. And uh is
this an interesting game?
He's showing how easy it is to jump the
whole time around, but he's actually
portraying very nicely what it what the
two sides are.
>> One side of the Hegelian dialectic.
Let's put Soros on the other kind side
of the Galian dialectic.
>> It's like white and black magic.
>> And Martin, the jumping backwards and
forwards
is very uh interesting, especially with
people like Gates for example.
>> Yeah. You just said that Musk then is
this side, then he's side, but now it
seems like Gates is doing the same.
>> Yes. And you know, these are all the
experts that we had to listen to just
because they have some dollars in their
pockets.
>> Yeah. Uh, we had some fun with him
during the
>> pandemic. Let's call it that. [laughter]
>> Let's see what he had to say.
>> Donald Trump wasted no time mocking Bill
Gates after the billionaire admitted
that climate change will not lead to
humanity's demise. In a memo released
yesterday, he wrote, "Although climate
change will have serious consequences,
particularly for people in the poorest
countries, [music]
it will not lead to humanity's demise.
people will be able to live and thrive
in most places on Earth for the
foreseeable future. He then went on to
highlight the biggest problem for
humanity, saying, "Although climate
change will hurt poor people more than
anyone [music] else, for the vast
majority of them, it will not be their
only or even biggest threat to their
lives and welfare. The biggest problems
are poverty and disease, just as they
always have been." Gates went on to
explain his position on CNBC.
Climate is a super important problem.
Um there's enough innovation here to
avoid super bad outcomes. We won't
achieve our best goal uh the 1.5 or even
the two degrees. And as we go about
trying to minimize that, we have to
frame it in terms of overall human
welfare.
>> But Donald Trump [music] was not having
it. The president of the United States
blasted the billionaire for his backflip
on climate change via a truth social
post that read, "I we [music] just won
the war on the climate change hoax. Bill
Gates has finally admitted that he was
completely wrong on the issue. It took
courage to do so and for that we are all
[music] grateful." MAGA. A group who
will not be happy with this news are the
climate change activists. People like
Greta Thornberg and her friends who have
spent their lives campaigning for
climate change awareness [music]
off the back of Bill Gates alarmism.
Gates became uncomfortable when quizzed
about the potential push back from
activists.
>> When the climate activists who who have
been very supportive of what you've done
and you've been very supportive of what
they done, read this and and if Greta if
Greta Thunberg is reading this and
saying to herself, my goodness, he seems
like he is reversing himself. What would
you tell her? I'd say, wasn't the goal
here to improve human lives?
>> Well, I'm fascinated how selective
climate change is. It only affects the
poor. The rich are not affected. You
know, they don't get hot when it gets
hotter. It's only the poor that get hot
when it gets hotter.
>> And Greta Tunberg with a little
sunflower in her hand or daisy or
whatever it is, a symbol of the sun and
sun worship. And uh amazing what expert
she has become. She has how many degrees
in climate change um Martin?
None. [snorts] None. None whatsoever
except that she has the means provided
by other secret societies in order to to
portray the agenda. So we don't want to
get rid of it
>> because we're now on a on a different
agenda.
But we we want to keep it in the cabinet
so that we can pull it out when we need
it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You Well, this is just to
show that even if Bill Gates decides to
turn to do a 180 degree on it, Prince
Charles and the Pope didn't. They got
together and they were talking about it
because of Leo to see. So, it's still
there. Don't get don't think it's gone.
Yeah. All right. So, let's just sum this
up and then we'll look at some other
aspects. Number one,
we're having this uh division in of
mankind into religious political blocks
where deities will be served in harmony
with tradition.
We have one little group that wants to
keep harmony between Christ and
scripture. they will not be welcome
anywhere.
That's the first thing. We have to get
rid of the divide between Christian
groups
>> because Christian nations are based on
traditional
principles which were dictated by Rome
in the Middle Ages and we want those
back. That's basically where we are.
>> Yeah. We'll keep climate change for for
when we need it and we'll do this and
that and the other when it's needed and
we'll play the Hegelian dialectic so
that people can be hearded in a
particular direction. But we need some
supernatural power to come in and assist
us with this chaotic situation.
>> So let's just look at this
externalization of the hierarchy that
was written by Alice A. Bailey who was
the successor of Blavadski, right?
>> And originally it was published by Lucus
Trust which is actually a downgrade from
a previous name which was Lucifer
Publishing House but it was too in the
face so they changed it to Lucus Trust
which basically means the same thing.
Now just as a reminder of what she said.
She said and this is basically in the
time just after the 1800s.
Thus a great and new movement is
proceeding and a tremendous increased
interplay and interaction is taking
place. This will go on until AD 2025.
Now remember this woman is a channel for
Lucifer
>> the devil.
During the years intervening between now
and then very great changes will be seen
taking place and at the great general
assembly of the hierarchy. These are
demonic forces
held as usual every century in 2025.
The date in all probability will be set
for the first stage of the
externalization of the hierarchy.
Now that could mean many things. It
could mean
>> and it's also interesting. It's the
first stage. So it's not a complete
thing yet. Well
>> first stage basically. Now what is the
externalization of the hierarchy?
>> That means something that was not
external is becoming external. So it can
mean that the demonic forces will
actually physically manifest themselves.
That's the one aspect.
>> Or it can mean that their behind the
scenes activity will become manifest.
>> Yeah. Their plans,
>> their plan will become manifest. So the
present cycle from now until that date
is called technically the stage of the
forerunner.
So can we assume that if the occult
agenda is on schedule that we're no
longer in the stage of the forerunner
but in the stage of implementation?
>> Yeah, it's definitely the f we're in the
year that this is this set to be taking
place and this is the first stage. So
obviously we must see some movements.
>> Correct. Now are we working according to
the Gregorian calendar and the papal
time system or are we working according
to the biblical one? Because it's
interesting that Albert Pike's book is
dated Masonically
and dated according to the normal dating
system. So obviously they're using both.
>> And it's fascinating that the Freemasons
use the same time schedule as given in
the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> The King James Bible.
>> Oh yeah.
>> And the theologians don't even use that.
They prefer the nonsense that comes out
of the Alexx.
Yes. So modern this forerunner stage it
is preparatory in nature testing in its
methods and extended to be revelatory in
its techniques and results. You can see
therefore that cohands masters initiates
world disciples disciples and aspirants
affiliated with the hierarchy are all at
this time passing through a cycle of
great activity. So who are these
masters? Those will be the ascended
masters. Those will be demonic guides.
>> Then you have the initiates.
>> Yeah.
>> Those are the high mason masonic
individuals and Jesuits who have direct
contact in their spiritual excises with
demonic forces.
>> And you'll have world disciples
and disciples and aspirants affiliated
with the hierarchy. In other words,
those working in harmony with
>> with the demonic
>> Yeah.
>> individuals.
[snorts]
Today human beings as a whole are so
loudly invocative
that the entire trend of the life of the
hierarchy and its plans to date have
been subjected to change to postponement
as far as certain interior and purely
hierarchal determinations are concerned
and to a hastening of certain plans
which were slated, if I may use such a
word, to take place several centuries
later
than this but which owing to the
unexpected preparedness of humanity.
Isn't that wonderful?
>> Yeah. So it actually it uh could be fast
forwarded because of humanity's
acceptance of it
>> because how beautifully they've been
brainwashed. Yes. Can take place not
prematurely really but securely and in
the fullness of time. This fullness of
time as regards the particular planning
with which we are dealing is from now
until 2025. She's pretty
>> yeah spot on, right? Martin document
2025.
>> Is it an externalization of the
hierarchy?
>> It's showing you the plan. That's why I
think as the more time progresses, the
more it will become clear what exactly
this is. um entailing but I'm definitely
sure for what you just said that project
2025 this the plans which used to be
behind the scenes are coming to the four
>> to the four I've made this practical
application and this immediate
illustration of teaching net glamour
illusion and maya because the whole
world problem has reached a crisis today
and because its clarification will be
the outstanding ing theme of all
progress, educational, religious, and
economic. Don't we have them all
together there now?
>> Yeah,
>> we see it. And we've spoken of all of
this.
>> Sounds like Revelation chapter 18.
>> Yeah.
>> Until 2025.
So, they've been working very hard at
the ecumenical movement to bring about
this religious unity. The Jesuits in
their university have been doing a lot
of nonsense education
and the economy is on board.
>> Yeah.
>> So there we have it. Everything is in
place. So Martin, what does the spirit
of prophecy have to say about this?
>> Yeah. So that we can make sense of
what's going on.
>> Okay, let's read it. As we near the
close of time,
there will be greater and still greater
external parade of heathen powers. Isn't
that externalization of the hierarchy?
>> Definitely.
>> And this is another individual, another
prophetic individual
writing in Letters and Manuscripts
volume 18 about the events that an
occultist has just informed us about.
>> Yeah.
Heathen deities, that's demons.
because there are no deities
will manifest their signal power and
will exhibit themselves before the
cities of the world. And this
delineation has already begun to be
fulfilled. So they will manifest
themselves.
>> And can that also be through the
influencing of
persons in power to implement what they
want?
>> Correct. And when people believe that
they are in contact with the dead
>> and the dead according to the scriptures
know nothing and will have no part of
anything that is happening here on this
earth because they are sleeping
waiting for a resurrection.
Then who is masquerading as this
individual?
>> It must be a demon.
>> Yeah. So that is an externalization
of the demon communicating directly with
humanity
>> and that's why it already uh that it
where she says it has already begun that
with the fox sisters was very prevalent
in her day already.
>> Correct. So the question is where do the
demons manifest their activity? Right?
>> Let's read it. God's presentation of the
detestable works of the inhabitants of
the ruling powers of the world.
>> Yeah.
>> That is that the political system?
>> Is that the ruling power?
>> That's the kings and the queens. Didn't
they just go and sit in a special little
chair constructed for them at the
Vatican?
>> Is that as a consequence of the inwork
of hierarchy upon the minds of men?
>> Definitely. In other words, isn't that a
direct selling out of Jesus Christ?
>> Yes. That is a a way of externalizing
the hierarchy.
>> All right.
So, the inhabitants of the ruling powers
of the world, who do what, Martin,
>> who [clears throat] bind themselves into
secret societies and confederacies.
Uh, didn't the president of the United
States just give instruction that the
Confederate general and basically the
Bible writer of Freemasonry should be
given his place of honor again?
>> Yes. Albert Pike was put on the pedestal
again.
>> And what are they doing? Not honoring
the law of God.
>> Whose law are they honoring?
>> The papacy.
>> Papal law.
>> Yeah. should enable the people who have
the light of truth to keep clear of
these evils. Can I be part of a
political system that is busy with this?
>> No.
>> Can I be part of a religious system that
is busy of this?
>> No.
>> If the religious system is dumped into a
category called Babylonian confusion,
mustn't I come out of it?
>> Yes, for sure.
>> Okay. more and more
>> when you see the papacy and the Anglican
Protestants getting together that
ecumenical soup run.
>> But that's nothing. There's no whimper
from any of the others.
>> Why are the Methodist Methodists not
screaming? Why are the Lutherans not
screaming?
>> Because they signed.
>> Hey,
>> they all signed.
>> What's wrong with them?
Okay.
So, God's people should be able to
distinguish these things and to keep
clear from all of these evils to come
out of them so that you're not part of
their plagues.
>> More and more will all false
religionists of the world manifest their
evil doings. For there are but two
parties.
Those who keep the commandments of God
and those who war against God's holy
law. But it says false religionists,
right? False religionists.
Would that include other religions as
well?
>> Yes. Because it's all false. It's not
according to what the Bible requires
>> as it's all against God's law
>> and it's manifesting.
So one of the mark characteristics of
these false religious powers
is that while they profess to have the
character and features of a lamb. So now
we're talking about basically the second
beast of revelation.
While they profess to be allied to
heaven, they reveal by their actions
that they have the heart of a dragon. So
this is when you see this church and
state that we've just shown so many
times getting together.
>> The dragon is demonic forces, right?
That they are instigated by and united
with satanic power. The same power that
created war in heaven when Satan sought
the supremacy and was expelled from
heaven. Now in these last days of this
earth's history, the commandmentkeeping
people of God by keeping his law are to
make earnest efforts to exalt the Lord
God of heaven. You can't keep the law
without honoring the lawgiver.
>> No.
>> All right. Aren't they a unit?
>> One and the same. The word of God is
specific,
marking to a certainty the opposing
influences against the seventh day
Sabbath, which is the sign of God and by
which the loyalty of the people is
tested.
So [snorts]
is Jesus God?
>> Yes.
>> Are you sure?
>> Definitely.
>> In the beginning was the word and the
word was with God and the word was God.
By him were all things created and
without him was not anything created.
>> Right? He is the creator God. And he set
a memorial in Eden which is called the
Sabbath. And he claimed to be Lord of
the Sabbath.
>> Mhm.
>> So is he going to set aside the Sabbath?
>> No. He won't get rid of it. No.
>> Why? Because I am the Lord. I change
not.
>> Okay. So Martin anything other than that
is pure apostasy.
>> So Martin when people make fiery
speeches on behalf of political
religious powers
are they acting under the principles of
heaven or under the principles of the
dragon?
>> You see that's why we've shown this
video a while back. But I think if we
take in context what we've just read out
of the externalization of the hierarchy
and out of the spirit of prophecy
and we look at it again. Let's see if
you can put it in context of what's
>> Let's have a look.
>> On his last day, Charlie Kirk was on the
top of a mountain and Charlie Kirk led
us there and Charlie Kirk has brought us
to the promised land.
Charlie's death was not just a murder.
The true word for what Charlie did
is sacrifice.
You see, the difference between murder
and sacrifice
is that sacrifice is a gift. Our
civilization will endure. The United
States of America will endure. For
Charlie, we will continue the mission.
For Charlie, we will end the evil
disease that split us and took Charlie
from us. And for Charlie, Turning Point
USA will last forever.
This is the place. THIS IS THE TURNING
point for Charlie.
When I see Erica and her strength and
her courage,
I am reminded of a famous expression.
The storm whispers to the warrior
that you cannot withstand my strength.
And the warrior whispers back, I am the
storm.
Erica is the storm. Our lineage and our
legacy
hails back to Athens, to Rome, to
Philadelphia, to Montichello. Our
ancestors built the cities. They
produced the art and architecture. They
built the industry.
Erica stands on the shoulders of
thousands of years of warriors of women
who raised up families, raised up city,
raised up industry,
raised up civilization,
who pulled us out of the caves and the
darkness into the light. The light will
defeat the dark. We are the ones who
build. We are the ones who create. We
are the ones who lift up humanity.
You thought you could kill Charlie Kirk.
You have made him immortal. You have
immortalized Charlie Kirk. You have no
idea the dragon you have awakened. You
know, Marco mentioned this arena and the
millions watching.
A couple days ago, I learned that Kirk
actually in German in German, the German
language
means church.
So on this Sunday morning, I'd like to
think we're all in Charlie's church.
Charlie or Christ
died at 33 years old,
but he changed the trajectory of
history.
Charlie died at 31 years old. But
because he had surrendered,
he also now has changed the trajectory
of history.
>> Pray again. Read the Bible again.
go to church next Sunday and the Sunday
after that and break free from the
temptations and shackles of this world.
He was a missionary with a noble spirit
and a great great purpose. He did not
hate his opponents. He wanted
the best for them. That's where I
disagreed with Charlie.
I hate my opponent
and I don't want the best for them. I'm
sorry. I am sorry, Erica.
But now Erica can talk to me and the
whole group and maybe they can convince
me that that's not right. But I can't
stand my opponent.
>> Charlie's angry looking down. He's angry
at me now.
[music]
>> All right. Now, I know that we've shown
that before. Just a few interesting
points. He says, "We've unleashed a
dragon." Well, the one speaker said that
>> the dragon gave him his power and his
seat and great authority.
>> There was spiritism in this because
Charlie is watching. [clears throat]
>> Mhm.
>> Is that dragon religion?
>> Definitely.
>> That is definitely not biblical
religion. Right.
Uh
um Hexet Hexet had a little mistake
there. Uh Kirk is Norwegian and not
German, but that's a minor little
detail.
So it's interesting that he should
invoke the name Kirk, which is Norwegian
for church. And they took it back all
the way to Rome and to Athens and
basically the whole statue of Daniel.
But Martin, where was Jesus?
>> Nowhere. The thing is like you what
you've just said, this is showing the
power of the other side.
>> Yes. And they were going to set it up
and it's going to last forever.
And in the Jewish Knesset, they said the
same thing. He will be remembered for
thousands of years. Martin, if the end
of the world should be coming now
and the real millennium be introduced by
Christ
>> and not down here on earth but as a
judgment in heaven,
then he will set up his kingdom. And
after that millennium, there will be a
resurrection of the unjust and a
destruction of the unjust and a new
heaven and a new earth will be created.
That's the biblical model, isn't it?
>> That's a biblical one. Yeah.
>> So, what model do we have here? Isn't it
a dragon model?
>> It's 100% a dragon model. Why did Trump
the whole time say this is the golden
age of America?
>> All right. Now, if this is a dragon
model, is it the externalization of the
hierarchy?
>> For me, putting it practically, this is
what we are seeing.
>> But can we have also a literal
manifestation of demonic power?
>> Yes, because Satan also has some plans.
Surely [snorts] he has some plans and
eventually he will manifest himself,
>> but uh we'll wait for that moment. Let's
just see what else is interesting in the
news out there in terms of other
manifestations.
The newly released video captured by a
US Reaper drone shows a glowing orb off
the coast of Yemen. Suddenly on the left
side of your screen, you see a Hellfire
missile zip in, strike that unidentified
object and bounce right off it. When we
slow the video down, you see the
Hellfire missile continue to travel on
its path. That trajectory becoming
clearer from this zoomed out angle. Not
shown is a second Reaper drone that
launched the missile. Congressman Eric
Verles shared the video at a House
Oversight Committee on what the military
calls unidentified aerial phenomena,
better known as UFOs.
>> That's a Hellfire missile smacking into
that UFO and just bounced right off. Um,
and it kept going.
>> It kept going and it looks like the
debris was taken with it.
>> Yeah. What What the hell is that?
>> A hellfire makes a hit, a kinetic strike
on something solid, there's usually not
much left of of whatever it is it's
hitting. A recent government report
revealed the government received more
than 750 new UAP sightings in the 2024
fiscal year, leaving lawmakers digging
into the mystery and national security
concerns posed by these objects.
>> Does this video scare you guys? Yes or
no?
>> Yes,
>> Wiggins.
>> Yes.
>> Me, too. There's a lot of information
that's not in that video, like what
mission they were on, and as they said,
what are we even looking at here? We do
know that the US military was conducting
air strikes against Houthi targets at
the time. Pentagon officials tell CBS
News. No comment.
>> All right. So, there's a lot of talk
about UFOs. We've talked about it in the
past. We don't have to repeat my own
personal experience with UFOs.
Then there was the report of this
massive comet that had some very strange
phenomena
and uh it could be an alien technology.
So the Harvard astrophysicist assessed
because it was not operating like a
normal comet. So there are strange
phenomenon and he claims the comet could
have been an artifact of alien
technology rather than a natural body
because its weight more than 33 billion
tons and spans at least 3.1 miles
across. So basically it could be an
alien city coming this way. Mhm.
[clears throat] But be that as it may,
we've always claimed that uh these are
probably demonic manifestations. Right.
Joe Rogan had a discussion with that
physicist. So let's just look what he
said. Things are getting very wild.
>> Yeah. There is a lot of misinformation.
You know, some people said I invented
three atlas this object uh in order to
distract attention from the Epstein
files.
>> Is that what people are saying?
>> Yeah. And I said, "Look, this object is
the size of Manhattan Island. It's at 4
and a half times the Earth sun
separation. Um, if I was able to put it
out there, you know, I would be more
powerful than the Pope." [laughter] And
because we're talking about a giant
object that you can see from any place
on Earth, you know, you can buy online
telescope that will allow you half a
meter in size that will allow you to see
it. It's out there. It cannot be faked.
Uh initially a lot of people were
dismissing your concerns and they were
saying that this object is nothing but a
comet and it's very normal. Uh but then
as it got closer and as we got more
data, it seems like you're correct.
>> Well,
>> this is a very unusual object.
>> There is something really important to
recognize here that usually when you
deal with scientific matters, they have
very little impact on the future of
humanity. Most of us continued as if
nothing happened. However, here if we
ever encounter alien technology,
everything will change. It will affect
the financial markets. It will affect
politics in a major way. So my point is
simple. This is different than other
scientific matters. And the intelligence
agencies know very well that events with
very small probability have to be
considered seriously because they have
they could have major implications. They
had one sentence at the end of the paper
saying maybe the trajectory was designed
and the editor said no no no the paper
will not get published unless you remove
that sentence.
>> Wow. So now when you when you listen to
comet experts that say well this claim
or that claim was never published in a
peer-reviewed journal guess what they
are the editors or the reviewers who are
blocking
the discussion on possibilities and I
think it's inappropriate especially in
the case of alien technology because
it's could be a black swan event. It
could be something that affects the
future of humanity and we if we behave,
you know, very conservatively, we might
not last very long.
>> Well, Martin, be that alien or not,
let's see what JD Vance just said on
October the 30th.
And I think that's more in line with our
thinking.
>> Mhm.
>> So maybe they're coming full t circle
and are realizing that there is an
externalization of the hierarchy. I
think we look 2025 is definitely not a
boring year.
>> No, it's not boring. So JD Vance says
UFOs, aliens could be spiritual forces.
>> Interesting, right?
>> As the vice president vows to get to the
bottom of the mystery, he says, "I'm a
big believer that there are things out
there that we can't explain. If another
person sees an alien, maybe I see an
angel or a demon.
>> You better choose which one you're going
to see. Right.
>> Definitely.
>> And aren't we supposed to test the the
spirits?
>> Mhm.
>> I think there are spiritual forces
working on the physical world that a lot
of us don't see or understand. Maybe we
see their manifestations.
>> Yeah.
At that point, Vance added that he
believes there are spiritual forces
working in the physical world that a lot
of us don't see and don't understand.
And he said he views the unknown through
the lens of faith rather than fear.
Is it aliens or is it our guardian angel
or a force that actively wishes to harm
us? I don't know the answer to that
question. And he said, "Well, Martin, if
it is a demon, he's out to harm us.
>> If it is an angel, he's out to help us."
>> How do we distinguish between those that
are of the light and those that are of
the darkness?
>> To the law and to the testimony.
>> Ah, if they speak not according to this
word, there is no light in them.
>> And doesn't the Bible say, "Woe to those
who call light
>> darkness and darkness light." Yeah.
Yeah.
>> And doesn't the
spiritual [snorts]
hierarchy do exactly that? We You
remember that guy in that video said the
light will
overcome the darkness. But he is
switching the two.
>> That's switching the two.
Very careful. Someone let's end with
Thessalonians.
For when they say peace and safety, are
they shouting that and handing out Nobel
prizes and dedicating them if they're
not in the right channel?
Then sudden destruction comes upon them
as a travail upon a woman with child,
and they shall not escape. But ye,
brethren, are not in darkness. Why not?
Because we have the light. What is the
light? It's the word of God. Thy word is
a lamp unto my feet.
that that day should overtake you as a
thief. Ye are the children of light and
the children of the day. We are not of
the night nor of the darkness.
Therefore, let us not sleep as do
others, but let us watch and be sober.
That's the bottom line.
>> This is what we have to do. So, we'll
still have to talk about how are you
going to stand? This is a precursor of
now to stand.
>> Okay. So, we've seen the ship striking
the iceberg. [clears throat] Iceberg is
error. Yeah.
>> And we have to strike it.
>> Yeah.
>> Then how are we going to stand? That is
still to come. So Martin, instead of one
lecture, it seems like we're going to
have three on this issue. And uh let us
just leave it there and say this is the
state of the world currently.
>> That's it.
>> It's in harmony with what scripture is
saying will happen to this earth. And we
see the powers that be aligning
themselves exactly like the Bible said
they would.
>> Yeah.
>> So I believe we are in the last days. So
let's pray.
>> Let's pray.
>> Heavenly Father,
we are indeed in troublesome and
interesting times.
And now the question must be decided
under whose banner do we want to stand?
Do we want to stand under the
bloodstained banner of Prince Emmanuel
or under the banner of the enemy
that bases his
his whole religion on traditions?
The traditions of men in vain they
worship me teaching for doctrine the
commandments of men. Help us to make
right decisions in Jesus' name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Heat.
[music]
>> [music]